DOCUMENT FROM THE PUBLIC,
CLAIMS TO THE CONTRARY ARE
PARTISAN BARKING AND YOU
OUGHT TO IGNORE THEM.
HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
SO, MARK, I THINK THE BEST
SUMMARY OF THE ARGUMENT
AGAINST THIS FROM THE
FEDERAL POINT OF VIEW CAME
OUT TODAY IN THE ONION WHICH
QUOTED AN IMAGINARY FEDERAL
OFFICIAL AS SAYING AND I'M
QUOTING IF WE TAKE AWAY THE
PUBLIC'S FAITH IN THIS
SHADOWING MONOLITH ALL
THAT'S LEFT IS AN EXTENSIVE
NETWORK OF ROGUE UNELECTED
RIGHT SUBJECTIVE AND
OCCASIONALLY PERSONAL
>> EXACTLY.
AND AS YOU NOTED, "THE
WASHINGTON POST" HAS COME
OUT AGAINST THE RELEASE OF
ABOUT WITH CATHERINE GRAHAM
THE LATE OWNER AND BEN
BRADLEY THE LATE EDITOR SAID
OH, YEAH.
I'M I WILL PUBLISH THIS AND
I'M PREPARED TO TAKE THE
RISK OF GOING TO JAIL.
AND TOM HANKS GETS ALL --
LOOKS FORWARD TO ALL THE
OSCAR NOMINATIONS.
EVERY ACTOR WOULD KILL TO
PLAY THE "WASHINGTON POST"
JOURNALIST WHO SAYS I'M
PUBLISHING THE MEMO AND
READY TO GO TO JAIL.
IN THE REAL WORLD OH, NO,
NO, YOU PEOPLE OUT THERE
DON'T NEED TO KNOW THIS IT
THERE IS A KIND OF CONFLICT
THERE.
>> Tucker: DEMOCRACY DIES IN
DARKNESS BUT NOT IN THIS
SPECIFIC CASE.
IS THERE AND YOU COVERED A
LOT OF NATIONAL SECURITY
STORIES FOR DECADES.
I HAVE READ THEM.
DO YOU THINK THERE ARE
LEGITIMATE REASONS TO
WITHHOLD THIS MEMO FROM
PUBLIC VIEW?
>> I DON'T THINK SO.
WE LI IN LEAKY TIMES.
SO FAR WE HAVE HAD AN
INVESTIGATION ABOUT SUPPOSED
RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
INTERFERENCE IN THE U.S.
ELECTION FOR WHICH THERE IS
VERY MINIMAL EVIDENCE.
WHEREAS IN THE COURSE OF THE
INVESTIGATION, A LOT OF
ELECTION, WHICH OUGHT TO BE
HAVE SEEN EMAILS REPORTS OF
MEETINGS:  PRIMA FACIE TEXTS
INSURANCE POLICY.
ONE BIG MASSIVE FRUIT OF THE
POISONOUS TREE.
THE POISONOUS TREE BEING A
FROM THE RUSSIANS, PURELY
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ENABLING
THE PARTY IN GOVERNMENT TO
SPY ON ITS POLITICAL
OPPONENTS.
THAT'S THE SCANDAL THAT'S
WHY THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
ENTITLED TO SEE THE MEMO.
>> Tucker: IF THIS MEMO WERE
NOT RELEASED AND CLOAKED
UNDER CLASSIFIED STATUS,
WOULDN'T THAT ABET THE MOST
DESTRUCTIVE KIND OF DISTRUST
IN GOVERNMENT AND CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND EXACTLY THE
KIND OF DISCOURSE THAT
REALLY DOES UNDERMINE A
COUNTRY IT SEEMS TO ME?
SUNLIGHT REALLY IS NEEDED
HERE.
>> WELL, YES.
YOU LOOK AT IT, IF YOU ARE
SAY VLADIMIR PUTIN AND YOU
WANTED TO INTERFERE IN
AMERICA'S ELECTION?
WHAT SERVES YOUR PURPOSES
MORE?
ACTUALLY CREATING CONDITIONS
WHERE THERE IS A PARALYZED
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE
PERMANENT BUREAUCRACY IN THE
GOVERNMENT AND MASSIVE
MISTRUST OF ALL GOVERNMENT
INSTITUTIONS?
I MEAN, IN EFFECT, THE
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION ITSELF
POINT.
>> I WOULD SAY ONE OTHER
THING TOO HERE, TUCKER, THIS
INVESTIGATION ISN'T WHERE IT
DURING THE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION DURING THAT
DISGRACEFUL SCOOTER LIBBY
INVESTIGATION A FEW YEARS
AGO WHERE BUSH TOOK THE HIGH
ROAD AND STEERED CLEAR OF IT
AND IT WAS IMMENSELY
DAMAGING TO HIM.
TRUMP ON THE OTHER HAND IS
SAYING THERE IS A BIGGER
PUNCHING THE SO-CALLED
RUSSIA INVESTIGATION.
>> Tucker: SO FAR THAT'S
RIGHT.
I THINK THE MEMO WILL SHINE